thanks very much Sarah Jane well hello
and welcome to the Daily climate show
coming up
clean energy super house the labor party
set out their Net Zero Energy Ambitions
[Music]
data shared exclusively with Sky News
reveals how much of the UK's offshore
wind capacity is owned by state-owned
Foreign companies
and at least five feared dead and
swathes of land swamps in the
Philippines after typhoon Nuru causes
heavy flooding
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and explore some of the potential
solutions to climate change so let's
start with the zero carbon power by 2030
that was one of the big announcements
from the labor party at its annual
conference in Liverpool now the shadow
chancellor has promised labor would
invest in green infrastructure including
clean steel gigafactories and carbon
capture if they win the next election
delivering clean power and growing the
economy will Rachel Reeves spoke after
the shadow climate change in Net Zero
secretary Ed miliband told the
conference it's cheaper to save the
planet than destroy it
let's hear it for doubling onshore wind
trebling solar power quadrupling
offshore wind tidal Power Nuclear
hydrogen power and all underpinned by
the best investment we can make 60
billion pounds over a decade to insulate
19 million cold drafty homes saving a
thousand pounds of bills cutting carbon
emissions mobilizing thousands of
businesses and yes friends led by our
brilliant labor local authorities up and
down Britain that's what I mean by an
energy policy for the people and the
planet
well joining me now from the labor
conference is Joe Pike uh Joe thanks for
joining us a big Focus then from labor
on a green future
yeah Leah they want to be seen at this
conference as a government in waiting a
lot of that of course is on the economy
because of the recent uh mini budget but
also on the climate we heard this
commitment uh trailed over the weekend
that labor if they get into government
want to be the first major major country
in the world to achieve zero carbon by
2030. I spoke to miliband yesterday who
as we saw in that clip of his speech
today was very a bouncy optimistic
saying that this will help create jobs
and also keep bills down
um a lot of this is to do is due to is
linked to solar power wind power the low
cost of both of those types of energy
but also looking at energy security and
how that is a bigger a challenge since
the war in Ukraine Eddie Miller and also
I think pretty happy to have a new
political enemy in a Jacob Reese smog he
was very critical of the government's
shifting position on fracking but also
saying that Mr E smog a business
secretary has an energy policy for the
1820s and also Lear that he is spreading
dangerous climate denial
Joe good to hear from you thank you very
much for that
well one of the policies touted by labor
today was a 100 clean energy mix by 2030
so it's good time isn't it to take a
look at that power mix and see where
it's sitting today and for renewable
energies it's at 59.4 there and of
course just uh 20.5 percent of uh fossil
fuels and most of that coming from gas
now conservationists have raised
concerns over the UK government possibly
scrapping or watering down farming
support meant to help for a green brexit
now the subsidiaries were planned to
change to a new UK system where Farmers
payments were determined on whether they
were helping wildlife and preventing
flooding rather than on how much land
they own however on Friday's mini budget
the government promised to review
regulations that affect farmers and the
department for environment food and
Rural Affairs has refused to deny that
the subsidiaries scheme are being
reviewed
now the cost of charging an electric car
using a public power points has gone up
by 42 percent in the last well four
months the RAC says it means drivers are
saving just one pence per mile over a
petrol car the rise has been blamed on
the wholesale
soaring costs of gas and electricity
it's fears that Pakistan could face
major food shortages after recent
flooding in the country wiped out
millions of crops officials say that
nearly 15 of Pakistan's rice crop and 40
of its cotton crops were lost at the
flooding across the summer which was
blamed in part on climate change killed
over 1 600 people and has displaced
Millions across the country
Now new data shared exclusively with Sky
News has found nearly half of the UK's
offshore wind capacity is owned by
state-owned Foreign entities
organizations in Denmark Norway Sweden
Italy China and France own more than the
UK which comes 12th on the list was guys
energy and climate change correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter joins me now thanks
so much for coming to the studio so just
give us a sense of what's going on here
and I suppose what it means for the
expansion of UK's offshore wind
facilities wind power is a critical part
of the UK government's commitment to
completely decarbonize electricity
Generation by 2035 and it's why we're
going to see more and more licenses in
the North Sea in particular coming up
for grabs and it's why because there's
no particular restriction on foreign
entities investing in renewable energy
as long as I didn't pose a national
security risk or a risk to energy
security bidding for those licenses
because they judge them to be a good
investment in their being proved right
right now wind power is a really
critical part of the energy mix but
critics say that because so many foreign
entities whether they're state-owned or
private businesses own a stake in Wind
capacity in the North Sea the UK simply
isn't benefiting enough from what is a
colossal natural Advantage the North Sea
has really reliable high wind speeds
which is why it's such a good place to
invest in electricity generation now
look Liz truss is not going to
nationalize energy generation in in this
country
but this data provided exclusively to
Sky News does add a layer of
complication perhaps to this argument
that we hear again and again that
domestic energy production because
remember foreign foreign entities own
oil and gas Assets in the North Sea as
well that domestic energy production of
any description really fully and
exclusively benefits the UK economy and
its public okay Hannah thank you very
much for that and of course you can get
more on this story and all of our other
climate news on the Sky News website by
following the QR code on the screen now
so do take a look now in the Philippines
at least eight people have died
including five rescue workers after a
typhoon calls flash flooding cutting off
Villages and leaving Millions without
electricity well typhoon made landfall
in bordeaux's town in The cuson Province
on Sunday night now the typhoon calls
gusts of up to 149 miles an hour on
Luzon where more than half of the
country is 110 million people live and
although individual storms can't be
directly linked with global warming the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has warned they are becoming more
frequent and intense as the climate
changes was guys Cordelia Lynch reports
it was sudden and intense typhoon noru
rapidly transforming into a super Thai
food battering buildings with sustained
winds of up to 150 miles per hour
it blasted the main island of Luzon in
the Philippines home to roughly half of
the country's population the intensity
catching many off guard
according to the Red Cross five rescue
workers were killed trying to help those
trapped in the northern Bulacan Province
we had lost five people who are rescuing
people that should have evacuated on the
other hand there were a lot of
evacuation so there's less casualties
but in the torrential downpour there
were some dramatic escapes
Philippine Coast Guard seen here lifting
a baby to Safety in San Leonardo
cradled and given Comfort one of twelve
rescued here
[Music]
by morning people were Waist Deep in
water Holmes damaged crops destroyed
sweeping destruction a demanding cleanup
ahead typhoons have hit the Philippines
with growing frequency in recent years
with farmers at the sharp end
there was no widespread loss of life but
it's on the move and unpredictable the
South China Island province of hey Nan
is bracing for a rainstorm and by
Tuesday the typhoon is expected to make
landfall in Vietnam Cordelia Lynch Sky
News
and finally to some news we could all do
with today the UK's largest zoo has
named one of their Asian baby elephants
Queen in honor of the late Queen
Elizabeth II who once met the calf's
mother on a visit to website Zoo
conservationists gave the honor of
naming the calf to their team who worked
in Thailand protecting the endangered
species in the wild and they chose the
name Nang Paya which is an animal
related Thai word meaning queen or
strong female Monarch well that's all
from us today thanks for watching